both Harley Quinn and the birds of prey
have a not that long yet pretty storied
history in the DC Universe and the
Margot Robbie LED flick pays tribute to
both if you're paying attention birds of
prey is all about Harley Quinn's big
breakup with mr. J but the Clown Prince
of Crime is at par Lee's only ex as
birds of praise animated prologue
explains Harley's heart was broken a
number of times before she hooked up
with the Joker
however Harley's one true love isn't a
homicidal clown it's poison ivy the
botanist turned eco-terrorist who's
proven to be quite a thorn in Batman's
side in the comics Harley and Ivy are a
very popular pairing and birds of prey
knows it that's likely why the female
face that turns up on the prologues
cartoon slot machine looks a heck of a
lot like Pamela Isley well it's
definitely not poison ivy it's pretty
obvious that Harley has a type birds of
prey isn't a direct sequel to Suicide
Squad the movie that introduced Robbie's
Harley Quinn to the big screen but it
clearly takes place in the same universe
while grocery shopping with Cassandra
Cain Harley recaps her story and
summarizes the events of her earlier
film a few shots from Suicide Squad
reappear in or were recreated for birds
of prey when Harley flashes back to her
origin story the connection opens the
door to one of birds of praise best
Easter eggs while breaking into the
Gotham City Police Department in order
to freak Cassandra Cain Harley catches
sight of a wanted poster on the wall you
might recognize that man if you've seen
Suicide Squad the man on the poster is
none other than Jai Courtney who played
Harley's teammate Captain Boomerang and
David Ayers superhero flick the DCE you
may not be as interconnected as the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but little
links like these are always nice
especially considering that boomerang is
expected to come back in James Gunn's
upcoming Suicide Squad film well in the
name like that how could you expect
anything different seriously the hell's
wrong to people for bad guys it's what
we do Cassandra Cain plays a big role in
birds of prey but she actually plays an
even bigger role in the comics as one of
Batman's many sidekicks
she's been Batgirl a superhero codenamed
orphan and assassin and one of the
deadliest women in the DC Universe
Cassandra Cain first appears in Batman
number 567 as the mute daughter of a
deadly assassin who raised her only to
quote speak the language of violence
that's a pretty comic book II concept
which is likely why the film makes some
major changes to the source material in
the birds-of-prey movie Cassandra is a
hard luck pickpocket with a rough family
life and a tendency to attract
sympathetic older female mentors she
ultimately ends up as an apprentice to
Harley Quinn sporting a similar look and
an identical love of breakfast
sandwiches considering that the comics
have seen her eternally passed over for
a larger role in the bad family maybe
the DCE used version of Cassandra Kane
made a better choice after all
Harley Quinn's kid apprentice is still a
better code name than orphan newsroom
hood when Renee Montoya comes by Dinah's
apartment to ask her to be her woman on
the inside of black mask's organization
Dyna refuses Black Canary tells Renee
that she remembers that her mom was a
hero who was left to die with no help
from the police well that's a pretty
convincing reason for anyone to stay out
of the superhero spotlight Dinah's super
heroic mother is a reference to one of
the most confusing retcons in DC history
Black Canary was one of the very first
super heroines and a central member of
the Justice Society of America
eventually the Justice Society of
America along with Black Canary were
retcon to exist on a separate earth from
the regular DC Universe later they were
rear ekend into the main universe and
the modern Dinah Lance was reimagined as
the daughter of the original
birds-of-prey wisely heirs away from
multi-universe high jinks in its runtime
but it seems that no matter the universe
Dinah's mother was always a hero elena
Bertinelli's character arc and birds of
prey is arguably the simplest when she
was a young girl her parents were gunned
down by a crew of mobsters led by
stefano Galante that's a pretty dead-on
adaptation of her comic book origins one
of them at least in her most famous
comics origin Elena's family is gunned
down by an assassin working for a group
of rival mobsters most notably stefano
mandragora and jr. Galante the movie
combines these two mobsters into one
presumably to keep the number of
on-screen assassinations within a
slightly more manageable scale
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah when she debuted in Suicide Squad
Margot Robbie's Harley showed a lot of
skin instead of the black and red long
johns that made her famous
Robbie's Harley sported hot pants a
short sporting jacket and a t-shirt with
daddy's little monster scrawled across
the front of it and folk cursive script
some fans love the new look
others found it sexist and needlessly
objectifying even Robbie seen mixed on
it she told the New York Times
I'm not wearing hot pants next time
still that Suicide Squad look is iconic
on its own and Harley can't escape it
entirely in the animated prologue
Harley's wearing her original Suicide
Squad get up her old outfit pops up
again later in the movie when Renee
Montoya is looking for something to wear
however even when Harley is dressed
entirely differently the Suicide Squad
influence remains if you look carefully
you'll notice that Harley has a tattoo
on her chest which also says daddy's
little monster just like a roll shirt
without Harley Quinn we wouldn't have
birds of prey without the Joker we
wouldn't have Harley Quinn and without
Jerry Robinson we wouldn't have any of
them while Bill Finger and Bob Kane get
all the credit for creating Batman it
was Robinson an artist who invented the
Dark Knight's arch-nemesis in 1940 Joker
isn't in birds of prey but his influence
looms large over the film as such it's
only fitting that birds of prey pays
tribute to Robinson's legacy when she's
captured by Black Mask and his goons and
pleading for her life
Harley tries to convince Roman that
she's good at finding things as an
example she brings up a nude photo of
Eleanor Roosevelt that the Joker once
had when the scandalous picture went
missing
Harley managed to find it in a bird's
nest in Robinson Park played by Rosie
Perez and birds of prey Renee Montoya is
Gotham City's toughest and smartest cop
even if she can't stop talking in 80s
cop movie cliches originally appearing
in Batman the Animated Series before
making the jump to comic books in Batman
number 475 Renee's long been a fan
favorite character and an important
member of Batman supporting characters
viewers don't get to spend a whole lot
of time getting to know Renee and birds
of prey before the craziness starts
still there are some nods to Renee's
most integral qualities most notably her
sexuality and knack were super heroic
mischief Ali Wong appears in the film as
Ellen Yee
Gotham City District Attorney and
ex-girlfriend of Montoya's as far as we
can tell Ellen is an original character
for the film but Renee's mixed business
and pleasure before she's dated bat
woman in the comics and former District
Attorney Harvey Dent had a long-standing
one-sided obsession with her and birds
of prey Renee ends the film by saying
goodbye to the GCPD and joining the
titular superhero team although she
doesn't take a codename on-screen she's
worked as a successor to the question in
the comics which is as good a code name
for Montoya as any and one of the most
relatable moments in the film
Harley tries to get over her breakup
with the Joker by buying a wildly
expensive pet that she might not have
the time money or space to take care of
slightly less relatable is the fact that
she chooses to by a vicious hyena Harley
names the hyena Bruce and a pretty clear
reference to Gotham City's most eligible
playboy billionaire Bruce Wayne however
what seems to be a spur-of-the-moment
decision for Harley is actually a deep
cut reference to the character's long
history in the cartoons and comics
Harley's often seen with her two pet
hyenas bud and Lou
even though birds of prey changes some
details it's pretty clear that Harley
without a hyena pads is like Batman
without his bats she's also got Bernie a
taxidermy beaver wearing a tutu the
entire movie is so wacky that it would
be easy to dismiss Bernie as just
another piece of zany set dressing but
the stuffed beaver is actually a popular
recurring character in Harley Quinn's
own comics as the story goes bernie
originally belonged to Harley's first
crush
young Harleen stole the taxidermy an
animal when her boyfriend was sent to
juvie like in the movies the Bernie of
the comics is dead but since Harley
certifiably crazy she treats him like
he's alive and able to speak anyway fans
of the injustice video game franchise
which pits DC comic book characters like
Black Canary and Harley Quinn against
each other in mortal combat like fights
have found a few similarities to the
games and birds of prey during one scene
in birds of prey Harley dresses up in a
stylish coat and hat in order to sneak
into the GCPD where Cassandra's been
locked up her outfit looks almost
exactly like what Harley wears an
injustice year - there's even a near
identical shot in which Harley tears her
coat open revealing heavy armaments
underneath it isn't just Harley who gets
the injustice love though Black Canary
does - at the climax in the movie Dinah
Lance finally unleashes
sonic scream decimating the black mask's
goons it's a big moment and it should
look familiar
jurnee smollett Bell who plays Dinah in
birds of prey all but admitted on
Twitter that she based her pose on
injustice his version of the canary cry
birds of prey doesn't have a poll post
ending sequence but it does have a nutty
little treat for fans willing to stay in
the theatre until the lights come up as
the final credits roll Harley's voice
takes over the soundtrack first she
makes fun of the audience for sticking
around even though the movie is over
feeling some pity for her fans however
Harley decides to let everyone who's
still in the theater in on a little
secret Batman fought and the audio cuts
off before Harley finishes spilling the
beans we don't know exactly what Harley
was going to say but we do actually have
a pretty good guess on the Harley Quinn
cartoon on the DC Universe streaming
service Harley made headlines for
suggesting that Batman has a very
intimate relationship with the flying
mammals he takes his name from it sounds
like Robbie's version of the character
was going to let moviegoers in on the
slanderous truth - yikes
no wonder Warner Brothers cut the audio
well guy dresses up like a bad clearly
as vicious birds of prey has a few
musical interludes but there's only one
that serves as a double Easter egg well
Harley isn't black mass captivity she
briefly loses consciousness when she
does she dreams that she's singing
diamonds are a girl's best friend
cinephiles will instantly recognize the
scene as a tribute to Marilyn Monroe's
performance and Gentlemen Prefer Blondes
but there's more going on in that scene
to Roman's Ionis is also there and
surprisingly it's not the first time
that you and McGregor has been part of a
musical number set to that one specific
song years before Ewan McGregor broke
bad and birds of prey he played the lead
in Baz Luhrmann's Moulin Rouge which
also featured diamonds are a girl's best
friend you might remember the scene when
Satine enters the film for the first
time as part of a lavish musical number
stealing the Gregor's heart forever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]